"Uncatchable",
Alexandr Zhelanov
...
-Alain Mabanckou,
vous avez dit un jour :
le danger, pour l'écrivain noir,
c'est qu'il s'enferme
dans sa noirceur.
Que vouliez-vous dire ?
-Je pense que le principe
même de l'écriture,
c'est de ne pas se recroqueviller,
c'est de ne pas rester à l'intérieur
de la case de son père.
Quand on écrit un livre,
on ouvre des portes,
on ouvre des fenêtres.
Et moi, je pense que,
en tant qu'écrivain africain,
noir, congolais,
je n'ai pas à m'enfermer
dans ce que les autres
attendent de moi,
c'est-à-dire que je sois celui qui,
24 heures sur 24,
parle de ma condition de Noir.
-Pourtant,
si on regarde votre oeuvre,
qui est abondante,
avec "Le commerce des allongés"
comme dernier livre,
qui est sorti à la fin
du mois d'août dernier,
bah, on est toujours,
grosso modo, on est en Afrique,
et souvent au Congo-Brazzaville,
qui est votre pays,
donc ça vous inspire
quand même beaucoup !
-Oui,
ça inspire dans le sens où ça,
c'est l'imaginaire,
ça, c'est l'ensemble
de ce qui tisse une oeuvre,
la géographie n'est pas en soi
la chose la plus dangereuse
en littérature.
Ce qui est dangereux,
c'est le fait de plaquer
des éléments qui sont,
semble-t-il,
constitutifs des individus.
Moi, je peux être au Congo
et j'ai une fenêtre
ouverte vers le monde.
Après tout, quand on lit les textes
des grands écrivains,
quels qu'ils soient,
ils sont toujours les relayeurs
de leur géographie,
ils parlent depuis leur territoire,
ils parlent de la Russie,
comme Tolstoï,
ils parlent de la Colombie,
comme Garcia Marquez,
ils parlent de l'Algérie,
je ne sais pas,
comme Boualem Sansal,
mais en même temps,
le discours qu'ils ont
a une dimension universelle,
parce que l'universalité,
c'est débord le local,
mais sans les murs qui sont là.
-Oui, et alors vous,
vous êtes citoyen du monde,
pour le coup,
donc vous êtes congolais,
mais vous enseignez aux Etats-Unis,
vous venez très souvent en France.
Et votre inspiration,
vous la puisez de tous ces voyages,
de toutes ces expériences,
et vous mélangez
tout ça ?
-Je pense aussi que
le voyage est quelque chose
d'essentiel.
Quand vous êtes un voyageur,
vous empruntez
la discipline du caméléon,
vous prenez la couleur
de l'environnement qui vous entoure,
vous avez ce que je rappelle
souvent aussi dans mes livres,
que j'ai puisé du côté
d'Amadou Hampâté Bâ,
c'est-à-dire l'attitude
du caméléon.
-Grand écrivain malien.
-Il va tout droit
et quand il veut
regarder à gauche,
sa tête reste droite,
il regarde seulement par les yeux.
-Alors, vous avez été,
honneur suprême,
très bel honneur,
professeur au Collège de France,
en 2106,
et vous avez prononcé,
à cette occasion,
une leçon inaugurale,
qui est une leçon absolument
magistrale, c'est le cas de le dire,
qui s'appelle
"Lettres noires :
des ténèbres à la lumière" et,
dans cet exposé,
qui est assez long,
vous avez pas la dent très tendre
pour vos aînés,
écrivains africains,
vous les critiquez en disant
qu'ils ont pas pris...
qu'ils se sont pas émancipés
comme il aurait fallu, hein.
-Je pense que
c'est un constat global,
il ne s'agissait pas simplement
de blâmer les aînés,
mais de blâmer une certaine pensée
de cette époque-là,
où il y avait
la pensée coloniale,
qui prédominait,
mais avant la pensée coloniale,
il y avait la pensée
des expéditions,
la pensée des découvertes,
la pensée occidentale
qui essayait de percer l'âme
du continent africain.
Et beaucoup d'auteurs
ont embrassé
cette sorte de littérature,
pensant faire du bien
au continent africain,
mais ils étaient là
en train de légitimer,
en quelque sorte,
la feuille de route qu'avaient
tracée les expéditeurs,
les colons, ceux qui avaient
les préjugés faciles
pour nous décrire.
-Vous avez déjà lu
"Le roman d'un spahi"
de Pierre Loti ?
-Bien sûr !
-C'est quelque chose, hein ?
-Ca fait partie,
vous savez,
ces littératures qui sont
des littératures
d'exploration, voilà,
les littératures
d'exploration étaient là
pour préparer
la littérature coloniale.
-Pleine de préjugés.
-Voilà, on explore et on essaie
de donner au lecteur
des éléments alléchants,
qui vont lui dire :
je n'ai pas peur d'aller en brousse,
je vais pas être mangé par le boa,
donc j'y vais !
Quand les Européens
- et beaucoup d'Européens
ne voulaient pas aller
dans les colonies,
il leur fallait une propagande,
c'est pour ça qu'on a eu
les "Tintin au Congo" d'Hergé,
qu'on a eu des affiches,
des publicités pour dire
aux pauvres Blancs qui avaient
peur d'aller en brousse :
c'est pas grave,
vous avez la belle civilisation,
allez-y !
Et donc, y en a qui disaient non,
d'autres oui.
Cette littérature
d'exploration, bon,
y avait toujours aussi des pépites.
Quand on est un bon écrivain,
quelle que soit, peut-être,
l'ambiance générale,
insalubre, qui peut exister,
y a toujours ces écrivains.
-C'est une pépite, pour vous,
le premier Noir qui a eu
le prix Goncourt,
qui s'appelle René Maran,
qui a écrit "Batouala",
en 1921, il a le prix Goncourt,
est-ce que ce livre,
qui est reparu d'ailleurs
assez récemment,
puisque c'était l'anniversaire,
évidemment, de cette...
Alors lui, attention,
il est pas africain,
il est guyanais,
mais il a beaucoup vécu...
il a été d'ailleurs
dans l'administration
coloniale au Tchad.
Que pensez-vous de ce livre ?
-C'est bizarre parce que,
dans cette réédition,
on écrit "Batouala",
on dit seulement "roman",
chez Albin Michel,
donc c'est déjà
une révision de notre époque.
Lui, quand il avait
publié son livre,
c'est "Batouala,
véritable roman nègre",
c'était ses mots, et donc là,
vous voyez, le titre n'est plus là,
c'est une sorte de révision,
et c'est agaçant, pour moi,
de ne pas respecter la volonté,
car ce sous-titre-là est important,
quand il dit
"véritable roman nègre",
ça veut dire que,
à l'époque où il publiait,
en 1921,
c'était les Européens qui étaient
considérés comme les écrivains
de littérature africaine,
et lui arrive en disant :
non, le véritable roman nègre
commence par moi,
"Batouala".
Et quand vous enlevez ça,
ça n'a plus de sens historique.
-Alors, "nègre", justement,
ça renvoie à deux hommes illustres,
qui sont Aimé Césaire
et Senghor, Léopold Sédar Senghor.
-On ajoute aussi quand même
Léon-Gontran Damas de Guyane.
-Vous avez complètement raison.
Et Senghor, par exemple,
vous en parlez
dans votre leçon inaugurale,
il a été très critiqué.
Pour beaucoup,
c'est un immense écrivain,
notamment pour les Européens,
très grand poète,
mais critiqué aussi par la jeune
génération des écrivains parce que,
justement un peu
dans la compromission entre...
D'ailleurs, il avait cette phrase
absolument incroyable,
il louait la raison hellène
contre l'intuition nègre,
disait-il, et ça,
beaucoup d'Africains
ne l'ont jamais compris.
-Je pense que c'était,
les gens avaient mal pris
la formule de Senghor
quand il disait que
la raison est hellène
comme l'émotion est nègre.
Et on a dit :
"ah, donc les Occidentaux
peuvent penser et nous,
"on est que dans le rythme",
dans ce sens-là.
Mais celui qui avait bien,
peut-être,
expliqué ce que c'était,
la négritude,
ce n'est pas un Noir,
c'est un Blanc et il s'appelle
Jean-Paul Sartre.
Il avait fait la préface
de l'anthologie de Senghor,
et cette préface est intitulée
"Orphée noir".
A l'intérieur,
il disait que la négritude,
c'est comme les Noirs qui,
à un moment,
plongent vraiment très loin
pour aller chercher
ce qui fait la substance
de leur âme.
Leur âme, c'est que le monde
que nous percevons chez nous
n'est pas que physique,
il est aussi ontologique,
au-delà de la réalité que l'on a.
-Et pourquoi c'est un mot
qu'on n'emploie plus ou, alors,
si on l'emploie,
on est qualifié de raciste ?
-Parce que les époques
ont un sens d'auto-destruction
linguistique.
On a peur de l'histoire,
parce que l'histoire, pour certains,
rappelle des fêlures.
On a peur, d'abord,
de dire le mot nègre.
Un Blanc aurait du mal à dire
"je croise un nègre",
mais les Américains,
quand ils s'appellent,
ils se disent nègres
entre eux,
mais ça n'a pas le même sens
parce que la société
nous a appris,
en quelque sorte,
à faire semblant d'effacer
quelque chose qui,
en réalité, a toujours existé.
Moi, je pense que
le racisme ne se combat pas
en faisant semblant
d'enlever les éléments
du vocabulaire,
mais en allant à la racine,
en expliquant que,
ce mot, même s'il est mauvais,
on peut le transformer.
C'est pour ça que le mot
négritude est né,
et il vient de nègre,
et les Senghor,
Césaire et Damas
en ont fait
une esthétique africaine.
-Est-ce que vous ne trouvez pas
que là, parce qu'on dit souvent
que l'Afrique est
un continent qui n'est pas
entré dans l'histoire,
ou un continent qui connaît
moult problèmes,
mais l'influence
de l'Afrique justement
dans les arts n'a jamais
été aussi importante,
dans la musique,
dans la littérature, jamais,
ne serait-ce
qu'en Afrique francophone,
y a eu autant d'écrivains
qui ont du succès,
dans le monde entier, d'ailleurs,
dans la mode, dans tous les arts,
c'est quand même quelque chose
qui est pas suffisamment noté, ça.
-C'est pas suffisamment noté
et je pense même
que ça a été oublié,
à un moment donné.
A l'époque de la négritude...
La négritude n'a pas été
créée que par des Noirs,
elle a été accompagnée
aussi par des Blancs.
-Vous dites avec Sartre.
-Voilà, Albert Londres,
Sartre,
Michel Leiris, Théodore Monod,
Albert Camus...
Beaucoup allaient du côté
de la rue des Ecoles, à Paris,
à la librairie ou la maison
d'édition Présence africaine,
où ils discutaient.
-Qui a été une grande revue, aussi.
-Voilà, ils sponsorisaient la revue.
Et à l'époque, même,
les Picasso et autres
s'étaient rendus en Afrique,
avaient vu les arts qu'on appelait
les arts nègres,
et ça a, en quelque sorte,
irrigué le mouvement
du symbolisme et du surréalisme.
Pour eux,
il n'y avait pas de doutes
que l'Afrique avait
ce côté mystérieux,
qui viendrait
à l'intérieur des arts.
Et aujourd'hui,
on le découvre petit à petit,
timidement, dans la mode.
Les grands couturiers,
dont je ne citerai pas les noms ici,
nous invitent,
pour les défilés qu'ils font
dans le continent africain,
parce qu'ils ont compris
que la mode, elle est là,
et que si les grandes vedettes
comme les Beyoncé,
les Jay-Z et autres
commencent à s'inspirer
de la manière de s'habiller
en Afrique,
c'est qu'il y a une esthétique
que nous avons négligée
depuis longtemps et peut-être
que c'est le chaînon qui manque
à notre humanité, à notre dialogue,
qu'on aurait en commun.
-Vous parliez tout à l'heure,
on parlait de la négritude,
on parlait des effets d'époque.
-Oui.
-Que pensez-vous
de la culture woke aujourd'hui,
grandement portée d'ailleurs
par les Afro-Américains
et qui consiste à remettre
totalement en question l'histoire
ou le courant historique
tel qu'il existe,
à condamner
des personnalités du passé
qui ont pu avoir,
effectivement,
des comportements que, évidemment,
aujourd'hui, on n'accepterait plus ?
-Je pense que, parfois,
dans des sujets
aussi délicats que ceux-ci,
il y a notre regard du présent
qu'on applique, directement,
aux agissements du passé.
Il faut, en quelque sorte,
aussi, s'assurer que,
si on veut rééquilibrer les choses
de manière,
dans l'histoire,
ou quelque chose...
il faut d'abord maîtriser
ce qui a été dans l'histoire,
il faut laisser, toujours,
à côté du lieu du crime,
les éléments qui permettront,
plus tard, à tout enquêteur
de pouvoir revenir sur l'enquête.
On ne peut pas forcément,
par la poussée du temps,
ou bien par le modernisme,
ou bien par le souffle
très brutal des débats,
commencer à tout équilibrer
en pensant que nous,
aujourd'hui,
nous sommes la civilisation
la plus achevée
ou bien que nous possédons
aujourd'hui le courant de pensée
le plus achevé parce que,
dans 50 ans, peut-être,
ce que nous pensons, nous, idéal
ne sera pas cela.
Regardez, dans certaines
régions du monde,
parfois, lorsque le modernisme
ou les nouveaux débats
les ont entraînés très loin,
ils commencent
à réclamer l'ancien monde.
Je riais beaucoup
en regardant certains vidéos,
par exemple, du Congo Démocratique,
où les gens font des grandes
cérémonies pour Mobutu,
alors qu'au moment où,
RDC, Zaïre, autrefois,
au moment où il mourait,
tout le monde voulait
s'en débarrasser.
Donc les changements
même les plus souhaités
ont leur mélancolie.
-Parce que le passé
est lourd, hein,
vous avez cette phrase
dans cette leçon prononcée
au Collège de France :
"Ce passé ne passe toujours pas,
il habite notre inconscient,
"il gouverne parfois
bien malgré nous
"nos jugements et vit en nous
"car il écrit nos destins
dans le présent."
Donc on est nécessairement
le produit de ce passé,
on est nécessairement habités ?
Quand vous écrivez,
vous êtes habités par ce passé ?
-Oui, on est...
Non seulement,
on est habités par ce passé,
mais le peu de temps
qu'on peut se permettre
de le mettre à côté,
il y a toujours l'autre,
qui viendra vous rappeler cela.
Nous sommes,
en tant qu'Africains,
des corps qui se déplacent
avec le poids de l'histoire.
C'est peut-être,
c'est là aussi
le paradoxe.
Moi, j'ai fait des études
en France où je me retrouvais
dans une classe,
on était 17 en troisième
cycle de doctorat,
et y avait 16 Blancs,
j'étais le seul Noir,
mais dans la foulée,
il m'arrivait d'oublier
finalement qui j'étais,
c'est quand les autres
me regardaient
que je me disais :
ah, en effet,
je suis encore une mouche
dans une casserole de lait.
Donc ça se voit de très loin.
-J'adore cette formule,
je sais plus où vous l'avez dite :
la France est toujours en sourdine.
-C'est toujours cela, moi,
je pense qu'il y a la lutte,
de la même manière qu'on lutte
contre les préjugés,
il faut lutter contre l'hypocrisie
de cette histoire,
dans la mesure où...
Pour qu'on puisse reconnaître
ce que je fais,
je dois le faire deux fois plus
que l'Occidental.
Parce que si je le fais
comme l'Occidental,
à quoi bon ?
J'ai pas la priorité,
puisque l'Occidental est là,
c'est lui qui le fera.
Mais si je le fais deux fois
et que l'Occidental n'y arrive pas,
là, je crée un élément peut-être
de dépendance même de l'Occident
vis-à-vis de ce que
je suis en train de faire.
On nous a toujours, peut-être,
mis dans une situation
où il ne faut surtout pas
être le dernier de la classe
puisqu'on vous a mis déjà
dans les derniers de l'histoire.
-Et alors vous avez
une autre formule
qui est extraordinaire,
vous avez dit que la colonisation
française avait
quelque chose d'affectif,
ce qui n'est pas le cas
de la colonisation britannique.
-Oui, dès que les anglophones
ont senti que l'heure
commençait à crépiter,
ils ont rangé les affaires
et sont partis,
ils étaient là pour les affaires.
-Pas partout, au Kenya,
ça a été violent,
la révolte des Mau Mau.
-Oui, mais grosso modo,
quand on voit
comment la France
s'accrochait à l'Algérie,
la France s'est livrée
à des référendums...
Donc la France
non seulement voulait
avoir l'aspect économique
de la colonisation,
mais administratif,
colonial, culturel, etc.
C'est vraiment
son "je suis le père de la nation",
en quelque sorte,
donc c'est pour ça que j'ai toujours
qualifié la colonisation française
qui était de l'ordre,
à la fois, aussi, de l'affection
dans le sens où la France
voulait s'assurer
qu'elle avait enlevé
dans le cerveau de son colonisé
tout ce qui avait trait à sa propre
culture pour mettre à l'intérieur
les éléments de la culture
qu'elle pensait être
celle de la civilisation.
-Alors, Barack Obama,
ancien président américain,
a dit un jour :
"L'Afrique n'a pas
besoin d'hommes forts,
"elle a besoin
d'institutions solides."
Vous êtes d'accord ?
-Oui, je pense que les hommes
prétendument forts
nous ont entraînés
dans le désastre qu'il y a
aujourd'hui puisque,
homme fort, en Afrique,
ça veut dire dictateur.
Ca ne veut pas dire
Margaret Thatcher,
ça veut dire quelqu'un
qui s'accroche au pouvoir,
qui change les institutions
ou alors,
avant de partir,
qui met ses enfants.
Donc quand Barack Obama
parle d'institutions,
il parle tout simplement
du fait que nous devons avoir
un renouvellement
démocratique
par le jeu de la Constitution,
par le jeu des lois,
nous devons respecter
l'alternance,
nous devons respecter l'opposition.
-Il y a pas eu de progrès
démocratique, pour vous ?
-En Afrique centrale ? Non.
-Pas en Afrique centrale.
-Non.
De temps en temps,
en Afrique de l'Ouest,
il y a des pays qui peuvent
être cités comme des exemples.
-Par exemple ?
-Jusqu'à une certaine mesure,
je pense que j'aurais préféré
être du côté du Sénégal
que d'être du côté de chez moi-même
parce que, au moins,
par la suite,
on avait un président
qui était parti pour aller
à l'Académie française.
Bien sûr, les conditions
de l'arrivée d'Abdou Diouf,
c'était le Premier
ministre, etc.,
mais ça s'était
pas fait dans le sang,
et puis y a eu des élections,
et puis Abdoulaye Wade est parti.
Nous sommes toujours,
en Afrique centrale,
la région dans laquelle
aucun président
ne quitte le pouvoir
et peut se promener dans le marché
pour aller acheter
du pain ou des arachides
sans pour autant
que le peuple lui lance des pierres.
-Justement, c'est intéressant,
parce qu'il y a les deux Congo,
d'ailleurs,
quand on est à Brazzaville,
on voit Kinshasa pas loin,
et quand on est à Kinshasa...
Le fleuve Congo fait quatre
ou cinq kilomètres de large.
Ce qui est intéressant,
c'est de voir l'évolution
de ces deux pays.
Le Congo-Brazzaville a eu
une période démocratique,
justement, dans les années 90,
et le président
Sassou-Nguesso était parti
et il est revenu, finalement.
Il était parti, d'ailleurs,
il était plutôt cryptocommuniste,
à l'époque,
et il est revenu libéral.
En revanche, au Congo-Kinshasa,
Mobutu a été chassé
du pouvoir et...
Bon, bah y a... là, y a pas
la même évolution, hein.
-Non, y a pas
la même évolution,
disons-le,
mais en même temps,
ils ont fait des élections.
-Voilà les deux,
Sassou-Nguesso à gauche de l'écran
et Mobutu à droite.
-Voilà, en même temps,
du côté de Mobutu Sese Seko,
après, par la suite,
y a eu quand même,
en dehors de la période
un peu nébuleuse
de Kabila père, et autre,
ils ont eu des élections
dans lesquelles
le président Tshisekedi,
qui est là,
est quand même le fils de l'un
des grands opposants,
qui a été... de Mobutu,
à l'époque, là.
Donc, dans une certaine mesure,
moi, je pense que le Congo
Démocratique, la RDC,
est en voie vers peut-être
un destin politique
qui ne va plus accepter
qu'un dictateur puisse squatter
le pouvoir pendant 30 ans.
Ils ont déjà essayé une élection
et je pense que ça ira dans ce sens.
Le tout, c'est de rendre
le peuple conscient
de la chance d'installer
une démocratie.
Installer une démocratie,
c'est permettre aux jeunes d'avoir
une certaine
courtoisie politique,
de respecter
celui qui vous critique,
tout comme célébrer celui
qui dit quelque chose de bien,
même s'il n'est pas
de votre ethnie,
s'il n'est pas de votre région.
Mais en Afrique,
on a toujours ce régionalisme,
comme au Congo-Brazzaville,
où les gens vont dire qu'il y a
d'un côté les mauvais,
les nordistes, et de l'autre,
les bons, les sudistes.
C'est faux, les bons et les mauvais
n'ont pas de géographie.
La bêtise et le bien peuvent
se changer de logement,
sans pour autant
qu'on s'en rende compte.
-Est-ce que vous savez
pourquoi la ville
de Léopoldville,
anciennement Kinshasa,
a été débaptisée
alors que, bah...
-Brazzaville.
-Brazzaville,
c'est Savorgnan de Brazza,
qui était un explorateur, aussi,
et on a gardé le nom, pourquoi ?
-Beh parce que, dès lors que,
à l'époque, au Congo belge,
dès lors qu'ils avaient
eu leur indépendance,
ils s'étaient lancés
dans une politique
qu'on appelait la politique
de l'authenticité,
la zaïrianisation,
disait Mobutu à cette époque,
on éliminait les traces,
vraiment, de la colonisation.
-Et une colonisation très dure,
avec le roi des Belges !
Le Zaïre, au début, était
la propriété du roi lui-même.
-Et dont il faisait don à la nation,
au royaume,
et donc,
par voie de conséquence,
puisqu'on était dans une période
d'authenticité,
on ne portait pas la cravate.
-L'abacost, oui,
c'est "à bas le costume".
-A bas le costume,
on portait l'abacost,
on ne portait pas la cravate,
pas de prénom chrétien, etc.
Mais le Congo d'en face,
de Brazzaville,
n'avait pas embrassé cela,
le Congo avait plutôt embrassé
l'idéologie marxiste-léniniste,
qui est une idéologie
somme toute occidentale.
Karl Marx et Lénine
portent des vestes !
Donc il y avait des cravates,
ils avaient gardé l'ensemble,
et il y avait aussi
le fait que Brazzaville
se sentait comme toujours
la capitale
de la culture de l'Afrique
équatoriale française.
Donc y avait ce prestige
intellectuel.
Or, le prestige
intellectuel passe
par la langue française,
les manières occidentales.
-Alain Mabanckou,
si je vous demande quel est
votre écrivain préféré ?
-Ah, sur l'Afrique,
j'aime beaucoup Camara Laye,
de la Guinée,
celui qui a écrit "L'enfant noir",
parce que c'était
l'un des premiers écrivains qui,
au lieu de se lancer
forcément dans une certaine
littérature de combat ou quoi,
avait pensé décrire
la cellule familiale africaine.
J'ai été enfant, j'ai joué...
J'aime les écrivains qui parlent
de leur enfance parce
qu'ils prennent leur singularité
pour l'exposer au monde
comme un exemple de la vie.
-Comment vous expliquez,
la France a quand même
un passé africain,
entre guillemets,
que la littérature africaine
soit pas davantage
enseignée en France ?
-C'est peut-être aussi
la crainte de ce qu'il y a
dans la marmite.
Quand vous voulez manger
quelque chose, voilà,
peut-être qu'il y aura
une nourriture allergique
à l'intérieur.
Ils vont enseigner
"Cahier d'un retour au pays natal"
d'Aimé Césaire
ou "Le discours
sur le colonialisme" ?
Ils l'avaient fait,
mais on l'a vite retiré
parce que certains textes
de la littérature africaine,
ce sont des explosifs
qui sont cachés,
ce sont des procès
contre la colonisation.
J'ai dit, "Batouala",
qu'on a montré tout à l'heure,
le roman de René Maran,
est la critique de la colonisation.
"Ville cruelle", de Mongo Beti,
"Les soleils des indépendances",
de Kourouma,
c'est la critique d'un monde ancien
face au monde nouveau.
Je veux dire,
un livre comme...
"Le devoir de violence"
du Malien Yambo Ouologuem...
-Yambo Ouologuem.
-...c'est aussi un mauvais visage
pour les Occidentaux.
Donc je pense que la France
n'est pas prête
à vouloir se faire
de l'autoflagellation,
depuis les bonnes écoles,
où les jeunes petits Français
vont se rendre compte
de la vérité telle qu'elle était.
Et donc,
on tourne en rond,
on cherche toujours des textes
qui restent calmes,
dans la littérature classique
française, voilà.
-Vous, vous avez écrit un livre
qui s'appelle
"Le sanglot de l'homme noir",
où vous dites aussi aux Africains
d'arrêter de se plaindre sans arrêt.
-Non, je veux dire qu'il faut pas
non plus qu'on soit sans cesse
dans la situation
de l'éternelle victime.
C'est-à-dire que je ne dois
pas définir mon destin
par rapport à la dose
de la victimisation
qui me caractérise.
A un moment donné,
je dois conjuguer aussi
mes verbes au présent
et c'est pas toujours...
-On vous a reproché ce livre ?
-Oui, quand je l'ai publié,
mais aujourd'hui,
de plus en plus de gens
viennent me remercier
parce que je dis des choses
qui se voient sur le terrain.
C'est ça, aussi,
la force d'un livre.
Les livres
les plus critiqués au départ
finissent par avoir raison
quand on arrive
à la ligne d'arrivée.
-Une musique ?
-Oui.
-Ce serait toujours
le grand orchestre de la RDC,
OK Jazz de Franco, voilà.
-Franco, qui était donc
un grand chanteur de République
Démocratique du Congo,
qui était le Zaïre, à l'époque,
et qui est mort, malheureusement.
-Voilà, qui nous a quittés,
qui est peut-être
une des grandes forces
de la rumba congolaise.
-C'est la rumba congolaise,
dansée par les sapeurs.
-Voilà.
-Et on entend "Mario",
un de ses principaux titres.
...
C'est sur cette musique,
magnifique,
qu'on va se quitter, merci,
Alain Mabanckou, merci !
-Merci beaucoup.
...
SOUS-TITRAGE :
RED BEE MEDIA
...